So I bought two people missing.
I'm here.
I gotta go live now.
Live now.
Hashtag ad.
You have to do create.
Go to the create tab.
And then you'll see the lobby.
And the password is... I can't say it out loud.
I think I just leaked it because it wasn't starred.
Wait, what?
I expected it to be starred and my game capture was not signed.
I packed the wrong person on Twitter.
Well, if they ask, it's not our fault.
We don't know what happened.
Yeah, I didn't do it.
It's not our fault.
I packed the wrong person on Twitter because, Mac, you don't have your own tag?
Yeah, dude.
Some fucking dickhead for the past three years took it and he updates his bio.
Active at this point.
We've hit a year.
So I can't fucking get it.
And he's been, like, trying to make me live.
So I just get a free promo, dude.
Yeah, dude.
Chat settings.
Wait.
Did he try to, like, extort you for money?
Yeah.
Wait, really?
How much did he ask for you?
Like, fucking 8K.
He asked $8,000?
He's smoking dick, dude.
Bro, what?
Yeah.
I literally just told him to fuck himself.
Holy shit.
8K.
I don't know how to turn on the voice chat.
What?
Proximity?
How do you do that?
I...
You want to fucking yell at people?
Or hear Taxi yelling.
Does he have to?
Is Taxi even in our group?
No, he got eliminated in Group A.
He got eliminated?
He got eliminated.
He got noobed out, dude?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
He was sweating this game hard.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Was he streaming this?
Yeah, he got... By the way, he got 10th, by the way.
Sometimes...
That won't be us.
Yeah, um...
Really?
Yeah, now I'm scared.
We're gonna get karma.
We're gonna...
I feel like we're getting cut, bro.
I'm literally just gonna see the first person.
I'm gonna run at them.
And then...
If my team helps me, then my team helps me.
Oh, to be fair.
To be fair.
RPR died first last...
Like, was the one to full wipe first.
What do you mean died first?
You were full wipe first last game.
No, it was...
It was Surefour.
You...
Remember he won the Gulag?
No, no.
Not that.
I meant full wipe.
He had a second res.
But you lost your second res first.
No, it was Surefour again that I got full wipe.
Are you sure?
Yes, because I remember when he said, There's one guy.
There's one guy.
Then I came on the hill and I died right after.
The frick is the voice chat settings.
In the audio.
You have to do it when...
It's not there.
No, you have to do it when we're starting.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait.
Why is...
Yeah.
Also, like...
Why can I only change voice chat when I'm in?
Now we have Nia Moka in our team because you're trolling, dude.
Yeah.
Fron is in this game.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to add my thing.
I like how you can talk with emojis in this game, dude.
That's true.
Let me see.
I told her to move and she moved.
Okay.
I need a...
Wow, you're so alpha.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Bring sure if...
Yo, Ducky.
You're in my arrivals on Twitch.
Oh.
Dude.
The sponsorship's going great.
Okay.
Hey, look.
That's not my fault.
My boss could have changed the game at any moment.
Oh, now you're blaming your boss.
Blame the boss.
You're the streamer.
Class on YouTube.
You're the favorite.
Listen.
My mods, dude.
Yeah.
I'm a streamer.
Alright.
Wait.
I need to pin the thing, too, for my chat.
I forgot to do that, too.
Hey, just checking.
The admin's asking where you are.
Bro, they're asking where you are.
We're all literally waiting for you.
We're all-
There's something random in our...
I think it's a random in our team, Slaughter and admin.
Or Phil.
Okay, let me do it.
They already got a sub for us.
Why is your name that, buddy?
Guys, I'm going to restart my stream so it starts on the... so the VOD is on the game.
That's insane, dude.
See, I'm a professional.
Hashtag add.
I'm restarting the game.
Restarting the stream.